hello everyone so as most of you are
aware last week we had tried to deliver
the lectures through YouTube live
streaming but that is no longer possible
because we are all working from home now
all the faculty members and the staff
and it is no longer possible to do it
that live streaming from the Center for
educational technology so what we are
trying out right now is to record our
lectures through some means right from
our homes and possibly deliver it to you
in some form possibly through you to
begin but this will no longer be live
streaming so last week we have been
discussing a lot about transformation of
stresses and in that context we had
simplified our case to a considerable
extent by discussing the case of plane
stress where we considered that Sigma
said that was 0 Sigma X said was 0 and
Sigma y 0 is 0 now all the discussion
had been quite abstract so to speak we
had not really considered a very
specific engineering problem this week
however we are going to apply the
concepts that we learned there to a very
very important engineering topic called
thin walled pressure vessels so
so as the name suggests these are some
kind of vessels in which pressurized
fluid is stored
possibly at some kind of high
temperature so when I say fluid I mean
it can be both a liquid or a gas
now as I already mentioned this street
can be at a very high pressure it can
also be at a high temperature
now the structure of these pressure
vessels is such that the walls are
relatively thin so as the name suggests
again that it's thin wall pressure
vessel now although it is possible to
have different shapes of these pressure
vessels but in practice in reality two
common shapes are very usually used so
these are the cylindrical shape shape
pressure vessels and spherical pressure
vessels so they're they look somewhat
like this
so there is a cylindrical pressure
vessel and for the spherical
so that's a better sphere
so that's the spherical pressure vessel
alright now the walls of these pressure
vessels are quite tennis I have already
mentioned now it is extremely important
to note that under the very very extreme
conditions of high pressure and
temperature it is very likely that these
pressure vessels may fail and when I say
fail it means that they may burst they
may crack open and that will lead to a
very very dangerous scenario in fact
these pressure vessels are being used
since a very long time they have been
used for more than a century in
engineering practice probably even more
but a proper understanding of how to
design these pressure vessels did not
come into being for a long long time so
what happened initially was said
although this pressure vessels was being
used widely they tended to fail and when
they fail they fail catastrophically
leading to a loss of life and there have
there are recorded there are records
that many many lives have been lost as a
result of simply the failure of these
pressure vessels so it is extremely
important that these are designed
properly and just like cars are designed
through various special protocols so
also there are special protocols in
place special codes in place to design
these this pressure vessels but before
we can before we can appreciate all of
those complicated things you know we can
understand the the fundamental
importance of the mechanical strength
the mechanical considerations which
which needs to be kept in mind for the
design of this pressure vessels based on
the very simple considerations of plane
stress which we learnt last week so let
us try to understand some of the
important considerations as far as the
stresses are concerned in these you know
in the construction of these
cylindrical and spherical pressure
vessels so first of all what we are
going to consider is the cylindrical
case now before we can launch into these
discussions some of you might be
wondering that whenever I am talking
about this cylindrical and spherical
pressure vessels why am i citing these
as examples of plane stress because when
we were discussing plane stress last
week we mentioned something like a shape
like somewhat like this that we had a we
had a flat plate like this a very thin
flat plate
so we set up our coordinate axis in this
fashion so this was our X and this was
our Y and all the important things that
we wanted to consider in the context of
this plane stress happened in this XY
plane so we were not really bothered
about things happening in the Z
direction now this is literally a plane
thing however neither the cylindrical
pressure vessel nor the spherical
pressure vessel is a plane thing so what
are we really talking about here when we
say that these are good examples of
plane stress so what we really mean
would be clear if we look at one of
these things so let's first take the
cylindrical pressure vessel and and and
maybe talk a little bit in detail about
about the justification of of the plane
stress consideration here so what we are
going to do is
so this is our cylindrical pressure
vessel and we are going to set up or
coordinate axis in this fashion
all right
so as you can see here the x axis is
along the longitudinal axis of this
cylindrical pressure vessel and the Y Z
plane is perpendicular to this
longitudinal axis so what we are going
to do first of all is to consider a
simple point anywhere on the surface of
this cylindrical pressure vessel and we
are going to consider a little element
around it so if we zoom this thing what
this will look like is this
so we zoom into that point
this is what is where it is going to
look like in fact we want to cut through
the thickness of this pressure vessel so
that the little slab element would look
somewhat like this now what we are going
to say is that on this surface on this
surface we are going to have some kind
of stress so let's call that as Sigma
and on this one on this side we'll have
another Sigma so let's distinguish
between the two Sigma's this is Sigma 1
and this is Sigma 2 corresponding you
will have Sigma here this will be Sigma
1 and this will be Sigma 2 now the very
fact that I have written them as Sigma 1
and Sigma 2 so if you remember the
lessons from last week you would
probably think that this Sigma 1 and
Sigma 2 were representations of the
principal stresses so why am i
arbitrarily assigning them these
stresses without knowing any further
details as Sigma 1 and Sigma 2 do I
perhaps mean them to be as principal
stresses so the answer is actually yes
so these happen to be the principal
stresses and the reason is not too
difficult to understand so you see what
is happening here first of all is that
there is a big approximation going on
here which helps us to look at this
intestine and you as a plane stress so
you seem as I've already mentioned a
number of times there is a fluid present
inside this
so there is a fleet present inside this
entire pressure vessel and that fluid is
very much putting a pressure on the
inside wall of this pressure vessel so
when we have isolated this little
element out there is a pressure from the
inside on this surface however please
note that there is no pressure on this
surface now it is quite wrong to say
that there is no pressure because of
course that mostly pressure is acting on
it but what we are going to say is that
on this bottom surface on this interior
surface there is going to be a finite
large value of gauge pressure gage
pressure means the pressure that is over
and above the atmospheric pressure on
the outside surface we have zero gage
pressure because the only pressure
acting there is the atmospheric pressure
so the pressure which is over and above
that most refresher is zero now the
moment I say that there is a large
pressure acting on the interior surface
of this you will immediately suspect
that this simply cannot be an example of
plane stress and it would be quite right
in suspecting that thing except for that
we have to note that it has been found
that these stresses the Sigma 1 and the
Sigma 2 they happen to be quite large in
fact they are much much larger than the
value of the pressure which itself is
quite high that is acting on the
interior surface so from that
consideration that this Sigma 1 and this
Sigma 2 is quite high compared to this
pressure which is acting from the inside
from that approximation we are going to
say that we are going to neglect that
interior pressure and the only
consideration for the little element the
littles
element this one would be due to the
Sigma 1 and the Sigma 2 and we'll see
later that indeed Sigma 1 and Sigma 2
the expressions will be of Sigma 1 and
Sigma 2 will turn out to be such that
they are much larger than P the pressure
which is acting from the inside so under
these considerations this happens to be
an approximately plane stress condition
furthermore you note that this is still
looking a bit like a curved surface but
in the limit that you take the
dimensions of this slab to be very very
small centered around this point it will
start to look almost approximately like
a like a very very small square is the
top top surface of this will start to
look almost like a perfect square which
is not curved and so from that
consideration also we can say that this
is approximately a plane stress
condition not unlike the example that we
had talked about in the last week as
regards to the to the to that thin plate
all right so now the question is why are
we saying that so that that answers our
first question that why why this is a
plane stress condition so approximately
we have understood that this is a plane
stress condition because this pressure
is very low compared to the Sigma 1 and
Sigma 2 and we are looking at a very
very small element a element or a volume
element around this point okay to answer
the other question that why am I writing
this a Sigma 1 and Sigma 2 perhaps
implicitly meaning that these are the
principal stresses the reason is that
this is a cylindrical pressure vessel
and it just so happens that it is so
nicely constructed that it happens to be
perfectly axisymmetric about the
longitudinal axis I repeat this it just
so happens that this cylindrical
pressure vessel is perfectly access
image
about this long channel axis so no
matter which side you look at it from as
long as you know you are staying on the
surface of this it look exactly the same
so if you look at this point you look at
this point as long as you are staying on
a particular ring around this axis it'll
always look the same so this situation
is what is referred to as an
axisymmetric situation and because of
the symmetry associated with that kind
of an axisymmetric situation it is
simply not possible to have any kind of
shear stresses appearing on this little
element so you cannot have any shear
stresses here you cannot have any shear
stresses here so this for this you do
not have to solve the mechanical problem
you can simply argue from the symmetric
ins considerations and we have seen
earlier in our transformation of
stressed lectures that those planes on
which the shear stresses do not appeared
the normal stresses that appear on such
kind of planes are referred to as the
principal stresses which is why in this
particular case also because this
particular surface is free from any
shear stress the normal stress which is
present here this Sigma it happens to be
one of the principal stresses in a
similar fashion again from symmetry
arguments we cannot have any shear
stress here and it also makes sense
because this surface is complementary to
this one so if this one doesn't have any
shape this one also cannot have any
shear and because this is a shear stress
free surface the normal stress which is
present here this one must be one of the
principal stresses and that's how this
one is one of the principal stresses and
this is one of the principal stresses so
that much should be clear by now all
right
then the next question is we have
understood what about the principle
about about this these two stresses
being the principal stresses but what
are the expressions are the related
to the pressure that is present inside
the answer is yes of course it is
because of the pressure only that is
acting from the inside surface that
these sigma1 and sigma2 appear in within
the within the ten walls of the pressure
vessel and the expression should
actually show that so our next task
would be to find out the expressions of
Sigma 1 and Sigma 2 in terms of the
pressure and perhaps having some
connection with the geometrical
dimensions but before we can find out
the the actual expressions what I'll do
is I just give give names to this Sigma
1 and Sigma 2
so what is usually done is is that the
Sigma 1
it is referred to as the hoop or
circumferential stress and the Sigma 2
is referred to as the longitudinal
stress
and the reason for calling this as the
hoop or the circumferential stress is
should be very clear because the Sigma
one is acting on this particular surface
and you can understand from the original
diagram that this one this particular
surface is actually coming from this one
and this one is this and we can actually
imagine that this is part of a large
ring like this so that is along the
circumference of this pressure vessel so
it is along the circumference of this
pressure vessel which is why it is
referred to as a circumferential stress
the the word who basically means a ring
so it's almost like a ring around this
pressure vessel so it's sometimes
referred to as a hoop stress also and
the other reason is quite should be
pretty self-evident that the Sigma 2 is
along the longitudinal direction and so
it is referred to as the longitudinal
stress alright so in the next page what
we are going to do is try to find out
the expressions on the Sigma 1 and Sigma
2 so first of all Sigma 1 that is the
hoop or the circle circumferential
stress
so for that I'll quickly redraw the
diagram
and what I'm going to do is considered
two cutting planes both of these cutting
planes would be parallel to the Y Z
plane so I'll consider somewhere near
this end somehow near this and one of
these cutting planes parallel to the Y Z
plane and another cutting plane which is
parallel to the Y Z plane but somewhere
around here and I will also consider
another cutting plane which will be
passing through the longitudinal axis so
this this axis so that plane would be
perpendicular to the Y Z plane so if I
do these three cuts what I will obtain
as a result would be something like this
so it is somewhat like this you
understand that this hashed part is the
thickness is a very very small thickness
of the pressure vessel now
on this entire thin ribbon-like surface
and on this entire thin ribbon-like
surface the stresses that are going to
show up are the hoop stresses or the
circumferential stresses so we'll
represent that by Fred
simultaneously we'll also have to take
into account the effect of the pressure
so that I'll represent by bloom
all right so if I want to write down in
the balance of the forces contributed by
this Sigma 1 and the back with with with
the force contributed by the pressure
what it should look like so I'm going to
consider the force contribution due to
the Sigma 1 here the Sigma 1 here you
understand that the thickness the
thickness here is T this entire
dimension
sorry
this entire dimension is twice R where R
represents the internal radius of the
pressure vessel
I repeat R represents the internal
radius of the pressure vessel so this
much is R
okay so if you want to write down the
balance what it should look like so
first of all I'm going to write down the
force contribution due to the Sigma one
so let me just quickly note down the
Sigma one here and the pressure here so
the blue one is the pressure the red one
is the Sigma one now if I want to write
down the force contribution to do Sigma
one it should be Sigma 1 times the area
now the area over which the Sigma one is
acting is T times this length so what is
this length so let us call this much as
Delta X so this will be T times Delta X
that's the total area but that is only
the area of this top ribbon we have to
take into account the Sigma 1 the force
due to Sigma 1 on this surface on this
little ribbon also so it's exactly the
same thing so what we are going to do is
multiply this by 2 now this should be
balanced
by the force contributed by the pressure
and that should be P times the total
area over which the pressure is acting
so this pressure is actually acting so
we have to consider this projected this
rectangular projected area we are not
going to consider the action of P as it
is acting on this internal surface no we
are not going to consider that we are
only going to consider this projected
area over which the P is acting so that
area is twice R times Delta X and that's
the total area we don't have to multiply
it by two so if you want to find out the
expression of Sigma one it should be
equal to
P
by tea
so PR by t
is the expression for Sigma one and you
please note that our happens to be much
much greater than T which means that
Sigma one must be much much greater than
P and R is much much greater than T
because what we are considering is
thin-walled Pressure Vessel
all right so the next order of business
would be to find the expression for the
Sigma 2 and we'll do that in the next
page so go into the next page will first
draw our cylindrical pressure vessel
once more
and we'll set up all coordinate axes
just as we had done earlier this is all
X there's our wine and this our said and
just like we had taken two cutting
planes earlier parallel to the y&z we'll
do that again but this time we are not
going to cut through with another plane
through the longitudinal axis we not
will do that so just we are going to use
two cutting planes parallel to the y and
z plane okay so if we do that the
picture that will emerge is something
like this
okay
shaking this hashed part represents the
thin wall of the pressure vessel now you
can all understand that on this ribbon
like
surface what I will have is a Sigma 2
and this Sigma 2 will be distributed all
throughout
but in the inside portion that means
here all in this inside circular region
what will I have
I'll have the influence of the pressure
acting so that I will represent by P
okay so all that I have to do is
consider the force balance between the
forces contributed by this Sigma to
distributed over this ring and the force
contributed by this pressure over this
entire circle so Sigma to twice PI R
into T it's going to be equal to P times
the area of that circle all right now
sorry I missed something here
they should be twice PI R into T all
right so from this I obtain Sigma 2 is
equal to be hard by twice T so this is
my expression
of sigma2 and again because my art is
much much greater than t the Sigma 2
will be much much greater than P by 2
and as long as we are talking only about
the orders of magnitude the Sigma 2 will
be much much greater than P also ok so
we quickly note that our Sigma 2 is
equal to half of Sigma 1 please note
that this is only true for the
cylindrical pressure vessel we'll see
what happens for the spherical pressure
vessel later on now before we proceed
further let us take a quick look at what
we have written on the left-hand side of
this initial equation so we have written
this thing twice PI R into T so when we
are writing this thing we are basically
assuming that the Sigma tube will have
very little variation over this little
thickness here over the little thickness
of the ring here the Sigma 2 will have
very very little variation so for all
practical purposes it's a constant value
all along this thickness so that we can
actually take this thing as twice PI R
into T please note that this is this
kind of an expression is only going to
work only if we have the condition that
R is much much greater than T otherwise
we have to do a proper analysis ok
now because we are considering a plane
stress situation and effectively plane
stress situation going back to our
previous lessons we can immediately
write down the expression for the
maximum in plane shear stress magnitude
so
so this is half of Sigma 1 minus Sigma 2
and that is nothing but we are by 14
please note that it is extremely
important that this expression that we
found out is only the maximum value of
the in-plane shear stress that is very
where that is when we are tangent to
this to this to the circular surface or
to this curved surface so when it
whenever we are tangent to this curve
surface in that plane this is the
maximum value of the shear stress
however if someone asks what is the
maximum possible value of the shear
stress this is not going to be the
correct answer
in fact for that we have to consider
that for this effectively plane stress
situation the stress in the direction
which is perpendicular to this plane is
zero well it is not zero if you consider
from the inside surface but at the level
of approximation that we are considering
that P is much much less than Sigma 1
and Sigma 2 and that and from that
perspective it is effectively zero and
the outside because it is it is a
specific pressure so the gauge pressure
is actually zero so so what what we
should be doing to find out the maximum
value of the shear stress would be to
write something like
so that'll be equal to half of Sigma one
so basically when you are writing half
of Sigma one what we mean is half of
Sigma 1 minus 0 where that 0 denotes
either the very small pressure compared
to the Sigma 1 Sigma 2 from the inside
or the actual 0 that we have on the
outside here so this is half of Sigma 1
and that we have seen is already equal
to Sigma 2 so this is equal to PR by
twice T and as you can clearly see this
PR by twice T is equal to twice the
maximum in plane shear stress value
which is PR by 4 T all right so next
what we are going to consider is the
spherical pressure vessel case so we
draw the will draw the sphere here
and we considered a little point
anywhere on its surface and we take a
little element around it now if we zoom
into this element
is going to look like this and we can
write as before our Sigma 1 here and the
Sigma 1 here the Sigma 2 here and the
Sigma 2 here and again we need to ask
also the question whether it is
justified to consider a priori these
things as Sigma 1 and Sigma 2 implicitly
meaning whether these are really the
principal stresses the answer is yes
these are indeed the principal stresses
because the planes on which they are
acting that is this plane and this plane
and the corresponding planes on the
other side here on on this edge and
along this edge
they are the principal stresses because
from spherical symmetry considerations
just like in the previous cylindrical
case we had access symmetric conditions
so here we have spherical symmetry
conditions which is even stronger than
the axisymmetric conditions so we have a
perfect nice symmetry in all directions
and so it is just not possible to have
any kind of shear stress on this surface
it is just not possible to have any
shear stress on this surface
correspondingly on the other surfaces
that are hidden here so because these
these are the kinds of surfaces which do
not have any shear stresses the the
normal stresses which are present on
those surfaces must be the principal
stress so this is one of the principal
stress and this is one of the principal
stress Sigma 1 here and Sigma 2 here so
the next important question which we
need to ask ourselves is that if there
is such a nice perfect simple spherical
symmetry so if all directions are kind
of symmetric then does it even make
sense to distinguish between Sigma 1
here and Sigma 2 here the answer is no
actually the Sigma 1 here is absolutely
equal to Sigma 2 so we can make that
point clear by writing here X
recently that Sigma 2 is going to be
equal to Sigma 1 this Sigma 2 is going
to be equal to Sigma 1 so what we really
want to emphasize here is that suppose
we had taken another point here and we
had taken a different orientation of our
element like this then also that
particular element would have shown
exactly the same value of Sigma one in
all the directions
okay so now the next question of course
is how can you find out the expression
of the Sigma one in terms of the
internal pressure and perhaps in terms
of some of the geometrical dimensions
here okay so towards that and what we
are going to do is we are going to
consider only half the hemisphere of
this of the sphere so the picture that
we are going to consider is this
okay and we are going to depict the
stress the Sigma one through this red
colored arrows
okay
and the influence of the pressure would
be shown on this in a circle like this
so again just as in the cylindrical case
we need to write down the force balance
between the forces contributed by the
Sigma 1 here and the force contributed
by this pressure here so Sigma 1 is
acting over this entire ring and just
like as in the cylindrical case we are
going to assume that because this
thickness is very very small for all
practical purposes there is no
distribution of the Sigma 1 over this
over this little thickness it's a
constant value over this entire
thickness so Sigma 1 times twice PI R
times T does the total force over this
entire ring and that should be equal to
the pressure times the area of that
inner circle so they should give me
Sigma 1 is equal to PR by twice T so
this is my expression for the stress the
in plane stress for the spherical case
now if I want to think about the maximum
in-plane shear stress then what should
be the value you please note here that
we have already we have all written here
that Sigma 2 is equal to Sigma 1 so we
have already found out Sigma 1 here
which means that Sigma 2 is also going
to be equal to PR by twice T then does
it mean that the maximum value of the
in-plane shear stress is equal to 0 the
answer is yes
this is indeed zero so the next
immediate question is if this is the
maximum in plane shear stress what is
the maximum possible value of the shear
stress overall so just as we had found
out the maximum value of the shear
stress by considering a direction which
is perpendicular perpendicular to the to
the thin wall of this pressure vessel
souls will be able to do the same thing
here and that is going to be equal to
half of Sigma one and please note when I
write this I actually mean that this is
half of Sigma 1 minus 0 and this will
come out to be PR by 14 so in summary
what we have managed to find out or what
we have learned here in this lesson is
that there are two important kinds of
pressure vessels cylindrical and
spherical pressure vessels which are
widely used in engineering practice we
have learned that in the thinness of
this pressure vessels plays a major part
in in simplifying the the understanding
and finding the expressions of the
various stresses present one of the
important things we learned was that in
the ways that we took the cuts the shear
stresses did not appear in both the
cylindrical and the spherical vessels
but it does not mean that the in-plane
shear stress is equal to 0 it is equal
to a nonzero value in the case of the
cylindrical pressure vessel as you have
seen earlier so let us go back to that
quickly so we did find it here the
maximum value of the in-plane shear
stress in the cylindrical case came out
to be PR by 40 but the maximum shear
value was twice that value it came out
to be PR by twice T here the cylinder
and the spherical case was a little bit
different it was much simpler to analyze
and we found out the maximum in pincha
stress was zero there was no difference
between the sigma1 and sigma2 because of
the perfect spherical symmetry all
around but the maximum shear stress this
turned out to be a non zero value it was
PR by fourteen so even with these
elementary considerations we are in a
position to do a number of problems all
right so we'll take that up later